un port qui tourne au ralenti et c'est
comme cela depuis plusieurs jours les
salariés de la cft ou bloquent les
différents accès pour ne laisser passer
que les canons de bananes destinés à
l'export un transports perturbés sur la
cacem des opérations au molodoï et la
raffinerie entravé plusieurs jours de
mobilisation mouvementée organisé par
une intersyndicale déterminé s'empare de
la concret reste immobile
s'ils veulent qu'on lâche un peu il faut
donc eu une bonne discussion en conquête
on veut avoir du concret qu ils veulent
des garanties sur leurs transferts de la
cft eu à la prochaine entité
gestionnaire du transport
même avec la garantie d'être tous repris
ils veulent être intégré dans une
structure unique avec les mêmes
avantages comme l'ancienneté et ne pas
être licencié durant cinq ans l'article
56 chambres 2012 prévoit les conditions
dans lesquelles les salariés doivent
être repris avec un nombre de détails
concernant les conditions salariales
les accords en entreprise curieusement
lorsqu'il a fait sa délibération du 17
décembre le conseil des ministres à sion
n'a repris qu'une partie de cet art
antique 56 dans son article 3 sans
réponse de la part des dirigeants de
martinique transports les syndicats
risquent d'accentuer la mobilisation en
cette période de fêtes voilà qui
perturbe quelque peu les derniers achats
de la population ils ont le droit de
revendiquer
lors du bon parfois au fait je pense que
bon certains benalisme que la population
s'y fondent l'un de vos niveaux de 200
commerciaux
comment s'organiser pour faire les
courses souvent nos besoins des enfants
on peut pas faire nos courses
convenablement et tous surtout si on
circule tout le temps il ya les sens il
ya les courses il ya tout et puis à les
enfants aussi pour lui faire et après de
choses qui entrent en jeu pour ce
sociologue les grèves de fin d'année
sont particulièrement que ce gène pour
la population à partir du moment où on
arrive à la fin de l'année avec la
société de consommation dans laquelle
nous sommes systématiquement les gens
vont consommer
la deuxième chose qu'il faut tenir c'est
l'inquiétude de ne pas avoir le manque
avec les grèves les blocages et c'est
donc on va avoir une population qui sans
doute va surconsommer au lieu de
consommer un peu naturellement qu'ils
consomment déjà beaucoup et la
surconsommation va être quelque chose
d'excessif des fêtes de fin d'année sous
tension une pression syndicale comme
outil de négociation
à quelques jours de noël